your body put a GPS pin in that man MH
and what you have to decide to do is to
feel it and to go ah there it is trying
to protect me again I'm good
now and you have that's got to be a
refrain a common always happening
refrain and you're going to have to make
sweet sweet piece with a journal and get
that crap out of your body onto the
paper because what your daughter's going
to feel as she gets older and older is
your chest tightening up every time you
think of that moment and then you look
at her and she's going to think that's
her fault whatever that thing that's
happening to mom right now she has to
try to solve
that and that's not her job